this is the biggest case related to gun
rights which has come before the supreme
court which is the highest court in the
land for more than a decade the supreme
court striking down a new york law which
had restricted carrying guns outside the
home
in doing so this court is expanding gun
rights at a time when public opinion in
many states favors further restriction
on gun laws it also comes at a time when
the senate is moving towards tightening
access to guns
just to give you a bit of context in
2008 the supreme court ruled that you
had the right to keep a gun inside your
home for self-defense new york state
however prohibited carrying guns outside
the home except for in certain
circumstances so for instance for sport
hunting um for going to a gun range
and also for those with certain special
licenses the supreme court reversing
that decision and has been criticized in
some quarters most notably by president
biden and who said in the last few
moments that he's deeply disappointed
with this decision the new york state
governor kathy hoechel says it's a
devastating decision both for her stay
and beyond and i think we can hear a
little bit of what she had to say
this decision isn't just reckless it's
reprehensible
it's not what new yorkers want
and we should have the right of
determination
of what we want to do in terms of our
gun laws in our state the federal
government will not have sweeping laws
to protect us then our states and our
governors
have a moral responsibility to do what
we can
and have laws that protect our citizens
because of what is going on the insanity
of the gun culture that is now possessed
everyone all the way up to even to the
supreme court
as you mentioned there wilfred as well
before this comes at a particularly
sensitive moment around gun rights in
america it's just weeks after that
enormous tragedy in uvalde in texas in
which 19 children
and two teachers were slaughtered inside
that classroom by a gunman who was
wielding an ar-15 rifle it also comes
just weeks after a racially motivated
shooting in buffalo in upstate new york
in which 10 people
were murdered there are also state
restrictions that come could come across
the supreme court justices desk on for
instance magazine right magazine
ammunition so the amount of bullets that
you can have inside a gun so there are
pending decisions that may also come
before the supreme court
this case also is indicative of the
legacy the continuing legacy of the
former president donald trump and how
he's still affecting laws across this
country during his time in charge he
appointed three conservative supreme
court justices it's known as a supreme
court hat-trick over here those supreme
court justices have been seen to favor
expanding gun rights they're also it
seems favoring reversing
the right to on access to abortion so
we're expecting that decision as well in
the coming days